hey David can you address the issue that
came up on Joe Rogan's show when you
were interviewed where Joe equated what
steven crowder did to Carlos Massa to
what Sam cedar does to Dave Rubin listen
I I actually in washing that back I
think that people may have misunderstood
I didn't interpret what joe rogan was
doing as actually equating the
homophobic harassment by steven crowder
of carlos masa to sam cedar making
videos about dave rubin but i do think
that i missed an opportunity to much
more clearly sort of explain my position
and the best way I can say it is when
sam cedar critiques dave rubin he's
criticizing dave rubin for what he says
not for who he is dave Reubens identity
plays no role in sam cedars critiques of
dave rubin dave rubin happens to be
Jewish dave rubin happens to be gay dave
rubin happens to be male none of those
characteristics have ever played a role
in Sam's criticisms of dave rubin when
steven crowder is including phrases like
lispy mexican queer when he is talking
about Carlos Mazda even if you want to
argue that the critique was about an
Tifa as as came up during my Joe Rogan
appearance you are getting into
critiques that are critiques of who
Carlos Mazda is as a person and what
where is that coming I don't know what
that is that is a very strange noise
apologies for that hopefully people
didn't hear very strange ringing noise
there it's I should have much more
simply laid it out in that way during
during my appearance with Rogen which
was to say the real difference is that
sam is critiquing ideas and not
including identity whereas steven
crowder is going hard on carlos Mazdas
identity and it just so happens that
that is a violation of YouTube's Terms
and Conditions so I apologize that I did
not do as good of a job as I could have
you know in the heat of the moment it
you you always come up with better
things to say after but my understanding
was that most of the conversation was
not literally Joe saying what Crowder
did is the same as what Sam did but
asking me what I thought
the differences were and I don't know
that I did the best job of explaining it
at the time although it did lead to this
funny moment where I said well if you're
saying that dave rubin has a cognitive
limitation then in a way maybe Sam is
going after him for a disability which
of course is not what I was saying and
it's not what I thought Rogan was saying
but it led to kind of a weird funny
moment we'll talk about that again and I
think that that is an issue that's going
to come up again on the program make
sure you get access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at WWJ Ockman comm or
a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show